SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLEY. DODD. DURAZZO.
EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO JONES. LAIRD. LYMAN.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGUE.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO.
SATO. SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND THE GUESTS.
BEYOND THE RAIL. PLEASE RISE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER BY BY
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. SO LET
US REMEMBER THAT WE ARE ALWAYS
IN GOD'S PRESENCE. HOLY MYSTERY
SURROUNDING US, POURING OUT YOUR
PRODIGAL ENERGIES WITH
PROFLIGATE INNOVATION. RECEIVE
OUR PRAYER OF AWE AND GRATITUDE.
WE CONTRIBUTE OUR PERSONAL MINDS
TO THIS ELEGANT UNIVERSE,
CREATING HARMONIES. THIS DAY
WITH ALL THAT EXISTS AND THE
MUSIC OF YOUR ALLURING PRESENCE
EVERYWHERE. WE JOIN OUR HEARTS
AND OUR IMAGINATIONS AND ALL OUR
PHYSICAL AND SPIRITUAL RESOURCES
REYES WITH THIS MAGNIFICENT
EVOLVING REALITY. K¾T REJOICING
IN YOUR PRESENCE ALWAYS. AMEN.
AMEN PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, WHICH STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
MERCY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. FULL
HOUSE. TODAY MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SENATE RULE 55 WILL
BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW GUESTS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. WE HAVE FOUR
PRESENTATIONS TODAY. WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE OUR UNDIVIDED ATTENTION
TO THE MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE SENATOR BRADFORD KICK US
OFF FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
DESK WITH HIS INTRODUCTION OF
HIS SPECIAL GUEST, SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND IT'S TRULY A
GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE TO
INTRODUCE SOME AMAZING YOUNG MEN
FROM EL CAMINO COLLEGE. THE
MEN'S SOCCER TEAM, BETTER KNOWN
AS THE WARRIORS. AND WE'RE GOING
TO WELCOME THEM TO THE SENATE
FLOOR TODAY. EL CAMINO COLLEGE
IS LOCATED IN THE CITY OF
TORRANCE, AND THESE YOUNG MEN
HAVE BROUGHT IMMENSE PRIDE TO
THE 35TH SENATE DISTRICT AND TO
THE SOUTH BAY COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE. THIS REMARKABLE TEAM LED
A HISTORIC SEASON IN 2023. THEY
SCORED 111 GOALS, BEATING THE
PREVIOUS ASSOCIATION RECORD OF
89 GOALS. THIS TEAM EARNED NINE
PERFECT RECORDS OF 24, PERFECT
RECORD OF 24 WINS, AND ONLY ONE
LOSS. THE WARRIORS WON THEIR
FIFTH STATE CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE
HISTORY OF THE MEN'S SOCCER
PROGRAM, AND THEIR FIRST SINCE
1992, AND FINALLY THIS TEAM WAS
RECOGNIZED AS THE 2023 NATIONAL
CHAMPIONS BY THE UNITED SOCCER
COACHES JUNIOR COLLEGE DIVISION
THREE RANKINGS. IT IS ONLY THE
SECOND TIME THAT ANY TEAM IN THE
COLLEGE'S HISTORY HAS EARNED THE
TITLE OF NATIONAL CHAMPIONS
SINCE THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL
CHAMPIONSHIPS IN 1987, THE
PEOPLE OF THE SOUTH BAY CAN BE
PROUD OF THESE INCREDIBLE
COMPETITORS, WHO ADMIRABLY
REPRESENT OUR REGION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION. I
WANT TO CONGRATULATE THESE YOUNG
MEN WHO HAVE JOINED US HERE
TODAY ON THE FLOOR, GIOVANNI
MEJIA, MARVIN GAMEZ, DONNA
DONOVAN, PALOMARES FRANCO DE
LUNA, AL-DEAYEA, RUA BOGART
ROCHA, DIEGO GARCIA, CHARLIE
CAZARES AND NICHOLAS BALTAZAR. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
AND THANK THEIR HEAD COACH,
MICHAEL JACOBSON, THE ATHLETIC
DIRECTOR JEFF MORA ON THIS
HISTORIC ACCOMPLISHMENT. LET'S
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
WE WELCOME SOCCER STARS TO THE
STATE SENATE. BUT WE'RE ALSO I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
RECOGNIZE THEIR AMAZING PUBLIC
INFORMATION AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS OFFICER, MISS KARRIE
WEBB. AND LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST, MY SEATMATE THIS MORNING
ON THE FLIGHT HERE TO
SACRAMENTO, EL CAMINO COLLEGE
PRESIDENT, DOCTOR BRENDA THAMES,
PLEASE WELCOME OUR GUESTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
PRESIDENT, YOU GUYS ARE IN
FRONT. YOU CAN'T HIDE IN THE
BACK. THE FIRST PHOTO WOULD BE
WITH SENATOR BRADFORD AND HIS
GUESTS.
IF ANY OTHER MEMBER WISHES TO
PARTICIPATE IN A GROUP PHOTO,
NOW IS THE TIME.
WE'LL COME BACK IN. 30S MEMBERS.
AND WE'RE BACK. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE OUR PRESENTATIONS WITH
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE STUDENTS FROM THE UC
DAVIS MEDICAL SCHOOL WHO ARE
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
THESE STUDENTS ARE PART OF THE
SUMMER SELECTIVE PROGRAM, WHICH
FOCUSES ON HEALTH POLICY AND
ADVOCACY. THROUGHOUT THE MONTH
OF JUNE, THESE STUDENTS, SHADOW
LEGISLATORS, ATTEND STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS, WATCH COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND BETTER COME TO AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. THE SUMMER SELECTED
PROGRAM PROVIDES AN INTIMATE
LOOK INTO HOW LEGISLATORS THÀNH
IS CREATED AND TEACHES THE
STUDENTS ABOUT THE STATE'S MOST
PRESSING HEALTH ISSUES,
ENCOURAGING THEM TO BE A VOICE
FOR THEIR FUTURE PATIENTS.
PATIENTS. EXCUSE ME, MEMBERS,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
OUR UC DAVIS MEDICAL STUDENTS AS
THEY EMBARK ON THEIR JOURNEY TO
BECOME PHYSICIANS.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME.
WE'RE MOVING ON. SENATOR UMBERG
HAS HER THIRD INTRODUCTION FROM
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SENATOR, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I'M
PLEASED AND PRIVILEGED AND PROUD
TO INTRODUCE A VERY TALENTED
YOUNG PERSON FROM MY DISTRICT, A
NATIVE SON OF SANTA ANA. I
WANTED TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
DIEGO SARMIENTO, WHO'S HERE WITH
US TODAY WITH HIS PARENTS, VERY
PROUD PARENTS. HE'S COMPLETING
HIS THIRD YEAR AT UCLA AND WAS
RECENTLY SELECTED AS A TRUMAN
SCHOLAR. THAT'S A VERY COOL
THING FOR FOLKS THAT DON'T KNOW
ABOUT TRUMAN SCHOLARS. THIS
SUMMER, HE'S GOING TO GO BACK TO
WASHINGTON, DC AND LEARN SORT OF
FIRSTHAND ABOUT GOVERNMENT AND
PARTICIPATE. IT'S A PREMIER
FELLOWSHIP FOR COLLEGE JUNIORS,
HE HAS BEEN ACTIVE IN LEADERSHIP
THROUGHOUT ORANGE COUNTY, BUT IN
PARTICULAR IN SANTA ANA, FOR
EXAMPLE, LEADING THE SANTIAGO
CENTENARIO VOTER INITIATIVE,
SEEKING TO ENCOURAGE SANTA ANA
YOUNG PEOPLE TO INCREASE THEIR
ENGAGEMENT IN CIVIC AFFAIRS.
HE'S JOINED TODAY WITH HIS
MOTHER AND HIS FATHER, VERY
PROUD PARENTS, VICENTE SARMIENTO
AND EVA SARMIENTO. AND SO,
COLLEAGUES, I ASK THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
OH BY THE WAY. OH, BY THE WAY, I
JUST HEARD TODAY, TOO, THAT FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE LAWYERS,
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO APPRECIATE
THIS. HE JUST GOT HIS LSAT SCORE
BACK. HE DID. HE DID PERFECT. HE
GOT A PERFECT SCORE ON HIS LSAT.
SO I'M GOING TO KEEP TRACK OF
HIM. SENATOR, BEFORE WE DO, WE
HAVE SOME OTHER MEMBER WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS TOPIC.
SENATOR BYRD, SENATOR ROMBERG,
HERE WE GO. OH, SENATOR ROMBERG,
WE HAVE ONE OTHER MEMBER WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ON YOUR
INTRODUCTION. SENATOR MINH,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I'LL KEEP IT
QUICK. I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
MEETING THIS YOUNG GENTLEMAN
EARLIER AS WELL. AND, WHILE I
DON'T HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING HIM, I'LL JUST SAY
HE'S AN OUTSTANDING YOUNG MAN.
I, TOO, LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO. THE APPLE
DOESN'T FALL FAR FROM THE TREE.
WITH TWO PARENTS LIKE THAT, THEY
SHOULD BE PROUD. BUT HOPEFULLY
HE FOLLOWS IN THEIR PATH.
CONGRATULATE US. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, SENATOR ROMBERG
. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. I'D LIKE
TO PRESENT THIS SENATE
RESOLUTION TO DIEGO AND HIS
PARENTS. SO THANK YOU, MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
I INVITE OTHER MEMBERS FOR THE
GROUP PHOTOS TO. NOW STEP IN.
WE'LL RESUME IN 30S.
UP NEXT, WE HAVE A PRO TEM WITH
AN INTRODUCTION. MEMBERS. THEN
WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER COLLEAGUE OF
OURS SAY SOME REMARKS BEFORE WE
CONGRATULATE THE SPECIAL GUEST.
MR. PRO TEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, WE
ARE WITH SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS
ROYALTY TODAY. I'M HONORED TO BE
ABLE TO JOIN WITH SENATOR
WIENER. AND SO MANY BAY AREA
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE ON THIS VERY SPECIAL
RESOLUTION THIS AFTERNOON,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
DODGER AND GIANTS FANS, WE CAN
PUT OUR DIFFERENCES ASIDE TO BE
ABLE TO HONOR A MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL LEGEND, ONE WHO'S NOT
KNOWN FOR HITS, RUNS OR A
BATTING AVERAGE, BUT FOR HER
UNFORGETTABLE VOICE BEHIND THE
MIC. WE'RE NOW BROOKS-MOON IS A
TRAILBLAZER. SHE SERVED AS THE
BELOVED PUBLIC ADDRESS ANNOUNCER
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS FOR
A QUARTER CENTURY. SHE IS ONE OF
THE FIRST BLACK WOMEN TO BE A PA
ANNOUNCER AND THE MAJOR IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL, AND SHE IS THE
FIRST FEMALE TO ANNOUNCE A
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME IN ANY
PROFESSIONAL SPORT IN ANY CORNER
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HER ENTHUSIASTIC VOICE ECHOED
THROUGHOUT ORACLE PARK FOR
NEARLY 2000 GAMES, INCLUDING
THREE WORLD SERIES
CHAMPIONSHIPS. BURNELL IS A BAY
AREA KID. SHE WAS BORN IN
OAKLAND AND SHE IS TAILOR MADE
TAILOR MADE FOR THE JOB THAT SHE
DID FOR SO MANY YEARS. HER
PARENTS WERE BASEBALL FANS. THEY
LOVED THE GIANTS. THEY USED TO
TAKE RENEL AND HER SIBLINGS TO
GAMES TO TEACH THEM ABOUT THE
GAME AND ITS HISTORY. SHE IS AN
ICONIC RADIO BROADCASTER IN THE
BAY AREA. I GREW UP LISTENING TO
HER ON KMEL AND SHE WOKE THE
BERY UP ON KISS 98 ONE FOR YEARS
WITH HER TOP RATED RENEL IN THE
MORNING SHOW. OVER THE DECADES,
HER VOICE BECAME AN ICONIC PART
OF BASEBALL AND SHE IS
RIGHTFULLY BEEN SHOWERED WITH
ACCOLADES THROUGHOUT HER CAREER,
INCLUDING BEING INDUCTED INTO
THE BAY AREA RADIO HALL OF FAME.
RENEL IS COMMITTED TO THE BAY.
SHE'S DONE INCREDIBLE WORK OF IN
THE BALLPARK AND OUTSIDE OF THE
STADIUM, SUPPORTING CHARITIES,
ACTING AS A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE,
AND HELPING WOMEN, GIRLS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR TO HELP THEM
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS. AND
WHETHER YOU ARE A GIANTS FAN OR
NOT, YOU'VE GOT TO ADMIT THIS
WOMAN WHO WAS STANDING HERE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR IS AN
INSPIRATION TO ALL AND SOMEONE
WHO IS ENRICHED THE LIVES OF
MANY OF US HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE, JOINING HER TODAY FOR
THIS WELL-DESERVED HONOR IS HER
HUSBAND, TOMMY, HER MOTHER IN
LAW, ODESSA, HER DAUGHTER,
MYESHA, HER GRANDDAUGHTER CARLA,
AND SO MANY OF HER FRIENDS AND
FAMILIES. COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ASK YOU TO BE ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE RENEL BROOKS-MOON
WISHING HER SUCCESS IN ALL OF
HER FUTURE ENDEAVORS. AND OF
COURSE, WE NEED TO DO A LITTLE
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS HONEYBABY
IN HER HONOR TODAY. AND MADAM
PRESIDENT, I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR
WIENER, TO BE ABLE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS. SENATOR WIENER, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT, AND
THANK YOU TO THE PRO TEM FOR
HONORING RENEL, SO I WON'T
REPEAT WHAT THE PRO TEM SAID
ABOUT THIS INCREDIBLE RUN OVER
THE LAST QUARTER CENTURY. AND
NOT JUST IN BEING THERE FOR OUR
GIANTS, BUT IN REALLY JUST
HELPING TO ELEVATE THE ROLE OF
WOMEN IN SPORTS, WHICH HAS JUST
BEEN SUCH A HUGE NEED. AND YOU,
YOU REALLY YOU INSPIRED A
GENERATION, PARTICULARLY OF
YOUNG WOMEN, TO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE NO THERE'S NOTHING THAT IS
OFF LIMITS TO WOMEN. SO THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE
DONE. BUT WHAT PEOPLE DON'T
ALWAYS KNOW BECAUSE PEOPLE KNOW.
REYNOLDS BEAUTIFUL VOICE AND HER
ROLE AND HER INCREDIBLE HISTORY.
RENEL IS ALSO DEEPLY INGRAINED
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY.
SHE IS EVERYWHERE WHERE I HOPE
SHE NEVER RUNS AGAINST ME. SHE
IS TRULY JUST SO DEEP IN THE
COMMUNITY. K¾T, FOUNDING MEMBER
OF FRIENDS OF THE FAITH, A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO BAY
AREA BREAST CANCER PATIENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPORT OR
INSURANCE, SHE HAS SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS COMMUNITY FUND. A
LONGTIME SUPPORTER OF GLIDE
CHURCH. AND SHE WAS THERE FOR
WHEN WE CELEBRATED THE LIFE OF
CECIL WILLIAMS AND JAN
MIRIKITANI BEFORE HIM, SERVING
ON SHE'S INVOLVED WITH THE GLIDE
FOUNDATION. SHE'S INVOLVED WITH
BUSTER AND KRISTIN POSEY'S A
WORK AROUND PEDIATRIC CANCER
RESEARCH, AND SHE'S ON THE
ADVISORY BOARD OF THE OAKLAND
INTERFAITH GOSPEL CHOIR. SO SHE
DOESN'T JUST DO A GREAT JOB AS
AN ANNOUNCER. SHE IS THERE FOR
THE COMMUNITY ON THE GROUND. SO,
RONNELL, WE LOVE YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR SKINNER,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, AND THANK
YOU, PRO TEM, FOR BRINGING THIS
HONOR TO, FOR US TO HONOR
RONNELL WHO DESERVES IT. AND
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR RELAYING THOSE
PARTICULAR, THE HOW COMMUNITY
MINDED RONNELL IS. AND I LAST
SAW RONNELL. OF COURSE, I, HEARD
HER MORE THAN FREQUENTLY AT THE
GIANTS GAMES, BUT I LAST SAW HER
JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AT
THE 50TH ANNIVERSARY OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES, WHERE SHE WAS
THE EMCEE FOR THAT INCREDIBLE
EVENT. AND I'VE SEEN HER AT MANY
SUCH EVENTS WHERE SHE VOLUNTEERS
HER TIME TO HELP THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE DOING SO
MUCH FOR OTHERS. AND THAT IS
TRULY, TRULY RENOWNED. AND OF
COURSE, AS AN OAKLAND,
HOMETOWNER, I VERY PROUDLY CALL
HER STILL ONE OF MY DISTRICT,
BUT I THINK MOSTLY AS I AM A
NATIVE OF SAN FRANCISCO, I WILL
LOVE HER FOR BEING THAT VOICE OF
THE GIANTS. AND I WILL SAY,
WHILE OUR PRO TEM WAS MUCH MORE
DIPLOMATIC, I'LL SAY BEAT THE
BUMS. SENATOR DODD, DO IT AGAIN.
YES, I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO GET UP
TODAY. I'VE BEEN A GIANTS SEASON
TICKET HOLDER FOR LONGER THAN
RONNELL WAS CALLING THE GAMES
BACK IN 2000 WHEN SHE CAME TO
WHAT IS TODAY ORACLE PARK AND
GRACED US WITH HER GREAT
PRESENCE. AND I'M NOT SURE I'M
TRYING TO JUST HIT ON SOME
THINGS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN SAID,
BUT SHE HAS CALLED FOR MORE
NATIONAL LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP
SERIES, AND SHE'S CALLED THREE
WORLD SERIES CHAMPIONSHIPS FOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS. SO
SHE'LL GO DOWN IN HISTORY JUST
ON THOSE THINGS ALL BY HERSELF.
I WAS I'M JUST SO DELIGHTED THAT
I AM HERE TODAY TO BE ABLE TO BE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES, TO BE ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE YOU AND YOUR
OUTSTANDING WORK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. PRO TEM. I'D LIKE
TO TURN IT BACK TO YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
TOLD, MISS BROOKS-MOON EARLIER
TODAY THAT SHE IS NOT ONLY AN
ICON, BUT. AND I GET EMOTIONAL
THINKING ABOUT IT. I FEEL LIKE
I'VE KNOWN HER FOREVER. BECAUSE
WHEN YOU HEAR SOMEBODY ON THE
RADIO GROWING UP AND YOU TRUST
THEM, THEY BECOME PART OF YOUR
LIFE. AND I TOLD MY MOM
YESTERDAY AND MY WIFE HOW
EXCITED I WAS THAT SHE IS GOING
TO BE HERE BECAUSE SHE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN PART OF OUR FAMILY'S
LIFE. AND SO, WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO, IF WE COULD PLEASE GIVE A
WARM SENATE WELCOME AND A THANK
YOU TO RENEL BROOKS-MOON. THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO DO A BAY AREA CAUCUS
PHOTO FIRST AFTER THE. AFTER THE
INDIVIDUAL PHOTOS, WE'LL DO A
BAY CAUCUS PHOTO. SO.
NOW FOR THE DODGER FANS. YOU CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE PHOTO.
THIS IS YOUR MOMENT. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE ONE GROUP PHOTO HERE.
GROUP PHOTO. GROUP PHOTO.
WE'LL COME BACK IN ABOUT 30S.
15 SECONDS. SENATORS 15 SECONDS.
ABOUT TO START.
AND WE ARE BACK. I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THREE EXECUTIVE LIVES
FROM MATTEL WHO HAVE JOINED US
HERE FROM IN THE GALLERY. IF
SENATORS. IF WE CAN GIVE THEM A
WARM WELCOME TO THE STATE
SENATE, WHERE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM MATTEL. AND THE FINAL
INTRODUCTION UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR IS THAT TODAY IS
SENATOR DODD'S BIRTHDAY. SO
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, SENATOR DODD.
MOVING ON TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. THEY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS.
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS
, RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MOTION. RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATOR RUBIO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, I WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
FILE ITEM A DASH 28 AB3 66 AT
PETRIE-NORRIS, JUST REMOVE IT
FROM THE SENATE ENACTED FILE.
THE DESK IS NOTED. SECOND
REQUEST BY MAY. REQUEST TO
REMOVE ITEM 75 AB 1880 FROM
ALANIS TO BE REMOVED FROM
CONSENT FILE. THE DESK IS NOTED.
SENATOR BECKER, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO PULL FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM
NUMBER 77 AB2484. BRIAN THE DESK
IS NOTED WITH THAT OBJECTION.
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR JUNE
3RD, 2024 THROUGH JUNE 6TH, 2024
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. WE ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
WE HAVE TEN ITEMS UNDER SECOND
READING FILE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 103. SENATE
RESOLUTION 44. ASSEMBLY BILL 996
1186. SECOND READING WILL BE
DEEMED READ. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
FILE ITEM 11. SENATOR LAIRD IS
PREPARED. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
FINAL ITEM 11 IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF NANCY LEE AND
DOCTOR GREGORY SARRIS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, BOARD
OF REGENTS. MISS LEE IS AN
ATTORNEY, CURRENTLY SERVES AS
CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE WALT
DISNEY COMPANY. DOCTOR SARRIS IS
A RETIRED UC PROFESSOR OF
HUMANITIES AND SERVES AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE FEDERATED
INDIANS OF GRATON RANCHERIA.
THEY WERE BOTH APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY 29TH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR DODD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. I'M SURE BOTH OF
THESE CANDIDATES ARE VERY WORTHY
OF THIS POSITION. BUT I'D LIKE
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF, CHAIRMAN
SARRIS, HE'S IN MY DISTRICT. I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT HE BRINGS
TO THE TABLE FOR THE UC SYSTEM,
TO BE ABLE TO BE THERE AND IN
PART, YOU KNOW, HIS HIS WISDOM,
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT HE HAS DONE
SUCH A GREAT JOB IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT, THAT I SERVE.
I JUST APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF CHAIRMAN SARRIS
FOR THIS GREAT POSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD.
SENATOR LAIRD, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DELI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOG AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ORTEGA SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYES
37. NO. ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. FILE ITEM 13. SENATOR
LAIRD IS ONCE AGAIN PREPARED.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
13 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
PATRICIA BARAHONA FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE STATE BAR
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. THEY ARE THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
YOUTH LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE AND
SERVE ON THE BOARD AS A PUBLIC
MEMBER, AND WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY 29TH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ANY DISCUSSION, DEBATE
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLI. I DON'T KNOW ALLEN GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA. BOGUE PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE CIERTO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. WILK. NÓ AYES 30. NOS.
ONE. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. AYES 29. NOES TWO.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
UNDER SENATE THIRD READING. WE
HAVE THREE ITEMS FOR ITEM 27, 29
AND 30. SENATOR DODD IS PREPARED
FOR FILE ITEM 27. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 153 BY SENATOR DODD
RELATIVE TO ELDER AND DEPENDENT
ADULT ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR DODD. MADAM PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
SCR 153, WHICH RECOGNIZES JUNE
2024 AND EVERY YEAR THEREAFTER
AS ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT
ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY, ELDER
AND DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
REMAINS A SERIOUS AND GROWING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA, TARGETING
PEOPLE FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS,
ETHNICITIES, AND WALKS OF LIFE.
THIS RESOLUTION ALIGNS WITH THE
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
RECOGNITION DURING THE MONTH OF
JUNE, AND HELPS TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND ENCOURAGE ACTION
FROM LEGISLATORS, ADVOCATES, AND
STAKEHOLDERS. IT'S CRITICAL THAT
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES WORK
TOGETHER TO COMBAT CRIME AND
ABUSE AGAINST OUR ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ADULT POPULATIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DISCUSSION. DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMON. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. AYE. OKUBO AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEGATO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN.
AYE UMMER. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
HURTADO. LIMON WHEN? AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
WE ARE HOLDING SENATORS. GIVE US
A FEW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HURTADO LIMON. AYE AYES
37. NO, ZERO. THE RESOLUTION
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
29. THE MAJORITY LEADER IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
155 BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
RELATIVE TO BREAST CANCER
AWARENESS. SENATOR GONZALEZ,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SCR 155, WHICH PROCLAIMS OCTOBER
2024 AS BREAST CANCER AWARENESS
AND PREVENTION MONTH. ACCORDING
TO THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY,
BREAST CANCER IS THE MOST
COMMONLY DIAGNOSED CANCER AMONG
WOMEN AND MEN IN THE UNITED
STATES, AND THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FROM CANCER IN
WOMEN. SPECIFICALLY, BREAST
CANCER IMPACTS EVERYBODY.
HOWEVER, AS MEN ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE DIAGNOSED WITH ADVANCED
BREAST CANCER AND HAVE LOWER
SURVIVAL RATES THAN WOMEN DUE TO
THE LACK OF AWARENESS AND
LIMITED KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE DISPROPORTIONATE
HEALTH OUTCOMES AMONG THOSE
DIAGNOSED, ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF
COLOR, WHO HAVE THE HIGHEST
MORTALITY RATE. SPECIFICALLY,
BLACK WOMEN. RECOGNIZING OCTOBER
AS BREAST CANCER. CANCER
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MONTH
WILL RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
INFORMATIVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
INCREASE AWARENESS AND NORMALIZE
SELF-EXAMINATIONS THAT LEAD TO
EARLY DETECTION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SCR 155.
THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DEL. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE OKUBO.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN AYE.
UMMER. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN ASHBY. AYE.
HURTADO. MCGUIRE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYES 36. NO. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION PASSES OUR FINAL ITEM
UNDER THIRD READING IS 530.
SENATOR RUBIO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATOR.
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 156 BY
SENATOR RUBIO, RELATIVE TO
INTERNATIONAL DAY OF PLAY IN
CALIFORNIA. SENATOR RUBIO, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SCR 156 ON BEHALF OF THE
GREAT SENATOR FROM SANTA MONICA
AND OUR COLLEAGUE, AS WE ALL
KNOW, OUR COLLEAGUE IS CURRENTLY
ON PATERNITY LEAVE, SO TODAY'S
RESOLUTION COULD NOT BE MORE
RELEVANT TO HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
AS WE KNOW, HE JUST HAD A LITTLE
BABY AND HAS AN OLDER SON, FOR
SOME OF US IT MEANS SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS. AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER FOR SO MANY YEARS, I CAN
ATTEST TO THE FACT THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE LOSING TOUCH WITH
REALITY SOMETIMES, AND SPENDING
WAY TOO MUCH TIME ON COMPUTERS,
IPHONES AND IPADS AND FOR SOME
OF US GROWING UP WITH TOYS, YOU
KNOW, IT JUST REALLY SPARKED OUR
CREATIVITY. AND SO I'M REALLY
HAPPY TODAY TO PRESENT THIS
BECAUSE PLAY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO OUR CHILDREN'S GROWTH. A
NUMBER OF STUDIES HAVE SHOWN AND
DEMONSTRATED THE POWER OF PLAY.
THEY PROVIDE A NURTURING WAY FOR
YOUNG LEARNERS TO FOSTER THEIR
IMAGINATION AND DEVELOP
NECESSARY LIFE AND SOCIAL
SKILLS. AS MENTIONED, OUR KIDS
ARE GROWING UP WITH COMPUTERS
AND TECHNOLOGY, AND SOMETIMES
THEY HAVE A REALLY DIFFICULT
TIME JUST KEEPING EYE CONTACT
WITH OTHERS. AND SO AGAIN, IT
WOULD BE REALLY NICE TO
ENCOURAGE OUR YOUNG INDIVIDUALS
TO CONTINUE TO PLAY, GO BACK TO
TOYS MORE PLAY TIME AND LESS
SCREEN TIME IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TODAY, THIS RESOLUTION
PROCLAIMS JUNE 11TH AS
INTERNATIONAL DAY OF PLAY IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS PART OF A
GLOBAL MOVEMENT RECOGNIZED BY
THE UNITED NATIONS. CALIFORNIA
HAS A LEADING ROLE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE WORLD OF PLAY.
CALIFORNIA'S CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
ARE VALUED AT OVER 500 BILLION
AND EMPLOY OVER 1.8 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. OUR STATE HAS
GIVEN ROUTE TO NUMEROUS TOY
COMPANIES OF ALL SIZES,
INCLUDING MATTEL, ONE OF THE
WORLD'S LARGEST AND MOST ICONIC
TOY COMPANIES. MATTEL IS
HEADQUARTERED IN THE DISTRICT OF
OUR COLLEAGUE AND SANTA MONICA,
AND THEY HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN SUPPORTING THE INTERNATIONAL
DAY OF PLAY. AS PART OF TODAY'S
RESOLUTION, MATTEL HAS DONATED
HUNDREDS OF TOY KITS TO
CHARITIES IN LOS ANGELES, SUCH
AS THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF
CARSON, SAVE THE CHILDREN AND
ELLIE'S BEST FOR ME PERSONALLY.
TWO WEEKS AGO, WE HAD A GRAND
OPENING, FOR AN AUTISM CENTER,
AND THEY WERE GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO
DONATE TOYS TO THE EASTER SEALS,
WHICH I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR.
EVERY LEGISLATOR HERE TODAY WILL
ALSO RECEIVE A TOY KIT TO DONATE
TO AN ORGANIZATION OR CHILDREN
IN NEED IN YOUR DISTRICT. YOU'LL
BE RECEIVING THEM. THEY LOOK
LIKE THESE RIGHT HERE, SO IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS, PLEASE REACH
OUT TO THE SENATOR FROM SANTA
MONICA FOR MORE INFORMATION. IN
RECOGNITION OF CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
AS A GLOBAL CENTER OF CREATIVITY
AND AS ELECTED OFFICIALS, THEY
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE WELL-BEING
OF OUR CHILDREN AND OUR YOUTH.
IT IS FITTING THAT WE PLAY A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THIS
INTERNATIONAL MOVEMENT,
RECOGNIZING THE VALUE THAT TOYS
BRING TO OUR YOUTH. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, SO I'M GOING TO HAVE THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE MINH. AYE. NEUMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OKUBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO SATO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
EGGMAN. AYE. HURTADO MCGUIRE.
RUBIO. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
UMBERG AYE. AYES 36. NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. NOW
ONTO CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE
ITEM 72 THROUGH 77. DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE SOMETHING
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR? I AM
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ALL THE ITEMS. ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION 14. ASSEMBLY
BILL 661 1852, 2397. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
FIRST ITEM. ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN HURTADO. MCGUIRE RUBIO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. AYE.
36. NO. ZERO. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED. RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IS TIME
FOR OUR ADJOURN AND MEMORIES.
AND WE HAVE ONE TODAY. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR, PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
SAN DIEGO HOMETOWN HERO AND
NATIONAL TREASURE, BILL WALTON,
WHO WAS A LEGENDARY BASKETBALL
CHAMPION, DYNAMIC ANNOUNCER AND
CARING HUMANITARIAN. BILL WALTON
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF 71
AFTER A PROLONGED BATTLE WITH
CANCER ON MAY 27TH, 2024, IN SAN
DIEGO. WALTON WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN LA MESA, CALIFORNIA,
WITH THREE SIBLINGS, INCLUDING
CATHY, ANDY AND BRUCE, WHO AT
SIX, SIX AND 250 POUNDS, PLAYED
SIDE BY SIDE WITH HIS YOUNGER
SIX SEVEN LITTLE BROTHER BILL AT
HELIX HIGH SCHOOL, BRUCE WENT ON
TO PLAY FOR THE DALLAS COWBOYS.
BRUCE AND BILL ARE THE ONLY
BROTHER BROTHER COMBINATION IN
HISTORY TO EVER PLAY IN THE
SUPER BOWL AND TO WIN THE NBA
CHAMPIONSHIP. BILL WALTON BECAME
SYNONYMOUS WITH ATHLETICISM AND
WAS TALENTED AT EVERYTHING HE
DID, ACHIEVING SO MUCH SUCCESS
CAME WITH INJURY WHILE STILL IN
HIGH SCHOOL AT HELIX HIGH
SCHOOL, HE BROKE AN ANKLE, A LEG
AND SEVERAL BONES IN HIS FEET,
AS WELL AS UNDERWENT KNEE
SURGERY BEFORE HIS SOPHOMORE
SEASON, WALTON UNDERWENT SURGERY
TO REPAIR TORN CARTILAGE ON HIS
LEFT KNEE. THESE EARLY INJURIES
TOOK A TOLL ON BILL THROUGHOUT
HIS COLLEGE AND PROFESSIONAL
CAREERS, AND HE WOULD FREQUENTLY
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE. HE WOULD FREQUENTLY
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT TO ME WHEN I
SPOKE TO HIM LATER IN LIFE, NOT
EARLY IN HIS LIFE. THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFE, WALTON CARRIED A
POSITIVE ATTITUDE AND AT ONE
POINT SAID, I'VE HAD 36
ORTHOPEDIC OPERATIONS WITH TWO
FUZED ANKLES. MY KNEES, HANDS
AND WRISTS DON'T WORK. I NOW
HAVE A FUZED SPINE. OTHER THAN
THAT, EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
WALTON WENT ON TO BECOME A
LARGER THAN LIFE FIGURE, ONLY
PARTLY DUE TO HIS NEARLY SEVEN
FOOT FRAME. WALTON'S UNIQUE ALL
AROUND SKILLS MADE HIM A
DOMINANT PLAYER AT UCLA UNDER
COACH JOHN WOODEN. FROM 1971 TO
1974, HE LED THE UNBEATABLE
BRUINS TO TWO NCAA CHAMPIONSHIPS
AND REMAINED LIFELONG FRIENDS
WITH WOODEN. WALTON THEN LED TWO
NBA TEAMS TO CHAMPIONSHIPS. IN
1977, HE LED THE PORTLAND TRAIL
BLAZERS TO VICTORY AGAINST THE
HEAVILY FAVORED PHILADELPHIA 76
ERS AND WAS NAMED MVP. FOLLOWING
THE SERIES, THE 76 SIXERS COACH
SAID BILL WALTON IS THE BEST
PLAYER FOR A BIG MAN WHO HAS
EVER PLAYED THE GAME OF
BASKETBALL. AFTER A SHORT LIVED
STINT WITH THE SAN DIEGO
CLIPPERS, WALTON JOINED THE
BOSTON CELTICS, WHERE HE LED HIS
TEAM TO AN NBA CHAMPIONSHIP IN
1986. ALMOST TEN YEARS LATER, HE
BECAME THE ONLY PLAYER TO HAVE
WON AN NBA FINALS MVP, SIX MAN
AWARD, AND REGULAR SEASON MVP.
IN 1993, HE WAS ENSHRINED INTO
THE BASKETBALL HALL OF FAME.
NOBODY WOULD HAVE GUESSED THAT
WALTON HAD BEEN A SHY YOUNG MAN
AND OVERCAME A LIFELONG STUTTER
WHEN HE EMBARKED ON HIS NEXT
SUCCESSFUL CAREER AS A SPORTS
BROADCASTER FOR OVER 20 YEARS,
HE WORKED FOR NATIONAL NETWORKS
AND NBA TEAMS. HE ENTERTAINED
AUDIENCES WITH HIS COLORFUL
COMMENTARY THAT INCLUDED
REFERENCES FROM THE CLASSICS AND
POETRY TO POP CULTURE AND
PHILOSOPHY. IN 2001, WALTON
RECEIVED AN EMMY AWARD FOR BEST
LIVE SPORTS TELEVISION BROADCAST
. IN TWO 2018, HE WON THE
COLLEGE SPORTS INFORMATION
DIRECTORS OF AMERICA DICK ENBERG
AWARD. ASIDE FROM BEING A
NATIONAL CHAMPION AND AWARD
WINNING SPORTSCASTER FOR YEARS,
BILL WALTON WAS AN ENTHUSIASTIC
CITY OF SAN DIEGO BOOSTER, A
TRUE EVANGELIST FOR THE GREAT
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO. IN
HIS FINAL YEARS, HE FOCUSED THE
MAJORITY OF HIS ATTENTION ON THE
CITY'S GROWING HOMELESSNESS
PROBLEM, CHALLENGING LEADERS TO
BE MORE EFFECTIVE. BILL WALTON
WAS ALSO THE FATHER OF FOUR SONS
WHO CARRY HIS SON'S GENES OF
BEING VERY TALENTED AND VERY
TALL. HIS SON, LUKE WAS AN NBA
PLAYER, WINNING BOTH THE 2009
AND 2010 NBA FINALS WITH THE
LAKERS. HE WAS HEAD COACH OF THE
SACRAMENTO KINGS FROM 2019 TO
2021. DURING THE HEART OF THE
COVID PANDEMIC. MY OWN LIFE
INTERSECTED WITH BILL WALTON'S
SON ADAM, WHERE WE BOTH ATTENDED
THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL AT THE SAME
TIME. WHEN I WAS MVP OF THE
TORREY PINES HIGH SCHOOL
BASKETBALL GIRLS TEAM, ADAM WAS
A TOWERING STAR ON THE TORREY
PINES HIGH SCHOOL BOYS TEAM.
NATHAN AND ADAM AND CHRIS ALL
PLAYED FOR VARIOUS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND WENT ON TO
SUCCESSFUL CAREERS. BILL WALTON
IS SURVIVED BY HIS SONS AND
THEIR FAMILIES, AS WELL AS HIS
WIFE, LORI MATSUOKA, ONE LITTLE
KNOWN BUT CHERISHED ASPECT OF
WALTON'S PERSONAL LIFE THAT
GIVES US A WINDOW INTO HIS SOUL
WAS HIS LOVE FOR MUSIC. ONE BAND
IN PARTICULAR WAS VERY DEAR TO
HIM, AS HE PUT IT, THE GRATEFUL
DEAD. THEY ARE MY BEST FRIENDS.
THEIR MESSAGE OF HOPE, PEACE,
LOVE, TEAMWORK, CREATIVITY,
IMAGINATION, CELEBRATION, DANCE,
VISION, PURPOSE, THE PASSION,
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT I BELIEVE
IN MAKES ME THE LUCKIEST
DEADHEAD IN THE WORLD. WALTON
WILL ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED FOR
HIS EXTRAORDINARY CAREER.
TOWERING HEIGHT AND LARGER THAN
LIFE PERSONALITY IN SAN DIEGO
WILL ALSO BE REMEMBERED AS A
BELOVED AND GENEROUS NATIVE SON
AND WITH THAT, I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN THE SENATE IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
MADAM PRESIDENT, AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM ENCINITAS
FOR BRINGING THIS ADJOURNMENT
FORWARD, BILL WALTON WAS A
LEGEND, NOT JUST AT UCLA, BUT
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA, ALL OVER
THE WORLD, IN FACT. AND I KNOW
DESPITE MY YOUTHFUL APPEARANCE,
IT DOESN'T SEEM POSSIBLE THAT I
COULD HAVE BEEN AT UCLA DURING
THE 70S. BUT INDEED, I WAS
DURING THE WOODEN AND WALTON
ERA, BILL WALTON, I GOT A CHANCE
TO KNOW HIM THROUGH VARIOUS UCLA
ACTIVITIES, AND HE WAS TRULY ONE
OF A KIND. BESIDES HIS ATHLETIC
PROWESS, HIS ENGAGEMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY WAS FANTASTIC. IN
EVERY ISSUE, FROM HOMELESSNESS
TO THE ENVIRONMENT. HE WAS A
TREMENDOUS ENVIRONMENTALIST. HE
ALSO KNEW MORE USELESS STUFF
THAN ANY OTHER HUMAN BEING I'VE
EVER ENCOUNTERED, AND WAS QUITE
PROUD OF ALL THE USELESS
INFORMATION HE COULD PROVIDE TO
YOU, THERE'S A RECENT
DOCUMENTARY ON ESPN CALLED THE
LUCKIEST GUY IN THE WORLD, AND I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO SEE IT
BECAUSE IT IS REALLY
INSPIRATIONAL, WE JOIN WITH HIS
FAMILY WITH LORI AND ADAM AND
NATHAN, LUKE AND CHRIS AND HIS
THREE GRANDCHILDREN, OLIVIA,
AVERY, ROSE AND CHASE AND
MOURNING HIS LOSS. IT'S A LOSS
FOR ALL OF US. AND I ASK THAT WE
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM ENCINITAS
TO ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR BIXBY,
PLEASE BRING THE HALL OF FAMER'S
NAME FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
JOURNAL. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER. GROVE, THE DESK
IS CLEAR, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 330, AT
WHICH TIME A MOTION WILL BE MADE
FOR ADJOURNMENT. WE RECONVENE
COLLEAGUES ON THURSDAY, JUNE
13TH, 2024 AT 9 A.M. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30
P.M, AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY, JUNE
13TH AT 9 A.M.